[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone its Peter Brown reading
Justin Clark's review of no man's sky
next nothing about the hype least a
disappointment and slow discipline
redemption of no man's sky has been
typical as such the great paradox of the
next update isn't exactly a surprise it
introduces some drastic improvements to
the bass game not to mention a great
deal of what hello games Sean Murray
promised and was pilloried for not
delivering at launch it is a grander
more cohesive experience that makes the
infinite expanse of space feel much less
lonely but what next really ends up
emphasizing through all of its quality
of life improvements and additions was
that the game we got on day one was
always going to be the game you start
out as an amnesiac astronaut stranded on
a random planet with a broken ship that
once repaired takes you on a potentially
never-ending search through a near
infinite universe though you begin as a
disadvantaged lost soul it's entirely
possible to study your surroundings take
advantage of what they have to offer and
become a social and military force in
the eyes of no man's sky as alien races
through multiple updates this has always
been the very soul of no man's sky ever
since the Atlas rises update you are not
alone is the first phrase another living
being speaks to you after you managed to
escape your starting planet there is an
enormous amount of fear hope and power
in that moment especially after spending
a couple of hours scouring your air SATs
home planet for the resources to repair
your ship the power of that statement
diminishes however the more the game
gives you command and comprehension of
your environment without a doubt no
man's sky has become a veritable sandbox
through a combination of new mining and
terraforming tools and the freedom to
build how and where you wish it has
never been easier to make any planet
into a home
multiple land-based vehicles now exist
making traversal even less of a
dangerous hassle
as for space frigates and fighter crafts
are easier to obtain there are more
missions available to haul in incredible
amounts of resources or if you're
looking to play the role of space pirate
seek out traders and fleets in other
galaxies and ransack them for sweet loot
all of this is made more enticing by the
fact that next fulfills the much touted
promise of true multiplayer for up to
four people can now party up and take on
the universe together it's not entirely
seamless that said you can still wander
around help people farm resources and
have backup while breaking into a well
guarded facility portals and
teleportation devices are now a staple
in no man's sky and showing off your new
home has never been easier either
altogether
no man sky's universe finally feels like
well the universe it feels like a fine
place to live a digital life while
simultaneously being the least
innovative or interesting thing the game
could become remember the paradox I
mentioned that's what we're dealing with
the good news is that the things that
always made no man sky great are still
very much here and they have seen their
share of improvements most notably to
the pacing and presentation it's rare
that graphics can make or break a game
but next visual upgrades truly make a
difference the worlds are vastly more
detailed with breathtaking new lighting
and physics effects enhancing everything
from pollen flying off plants as they
sway in the breeze to gravity and light
being vacuumed into the yawning void of
a black hole the third-person camera not
only grants the game a sense of scale
but also gives you a better
understanding of exactly who you are in
the universe especially since the look
and species of your character is now
customisable at Space Station's the
improved effects in space make an
already magnificent environment even
more amazing especially with ring
planets now a common sight
where much of the game's initial hours
are still spent introducing you to the
core mechanics they are now far more
deeply embedded in narrative conceit you
are wholly unaware of who you are your
place in the universe and who is guiding
you along every new bit of information
is found by you clued in by anomalous
broadcast from derelict equipment strewn
across the universe learning from the
failures of other explorers there are
aliens but their help is unreliable
until you put the time and effort into
learning their language you do this
either by getting one of the aliens to
teach you new words or by finding the
species codices scattered and foreign
monuments there are many more of these
opportunities now especially in space
stations which have been redesigned as
wide open forums where one might find
friends bragging about new discoveries
here is stranger to them all at first
and it's only in choosing to take the
risk of ingratiate you can find yourself
in a species favor with their
representatives willing to offer help in
your hours of need all of this is in
favor of the artemis and alice paths
storylines introduced in 2017 Atlas
Rises update the narrative beats of each
story are largely unchanged but they are
both now far better integrated into the
flow of the game as rewards for your
curiosity rather than staunch waypoints
impatiently waiting for your arrival
that said players returning to old saves
will find it's not as easy as just
picking up where they left off and much
of what they already own gets shuffled
around at random it doesn't break
pre-existing games but it's a less than
welcome relearning curve to be sure both
narratives still have their positives
and negatives though the original Alice
path storyline is now a minor footnote
in a journey much wider in scope but
what matters most is that both
narratives encourage the things that
distinguish no man's sky
[Music]
at its absolute best no man's sky is a
measured gentle experience where you are
rarely the agent of change but a
perpetual visitor who is constantly
dwarfed by the magnitude of a universe
neutral to your presence it's not your
job in these stories to colonize the
universe your job is to comprehend it
your job is to recognize the
spirituality in the primary gimmick of
no man's sky since day one has been off
the best things about the next update
feed that gimmick while features like
multiplayer and base building certainly
put more proverbial asses and seats
they're also the least memorable
additions to an otherwise thoughtful
experience
[Music]
[Music]